[Music]
in ursula k le guin's third earth sea
novel the farthest shore
little bit before the halfway point of
the book we see ged the ark mage taking
aaron with him
in disguise as just ordinary people
going to two of the many islands of
earth sea to try to figure out what's
actually happening to try to trace the
trouble
to its source and at one point
this is in chapter six
ged sparrowhawk
says that i think we must come not only
to a place
but a person
this is evil evil what passes on this
island this loss of craft and pride this
joylessness this waste this is the work
of an evil will
but a will not even bent here not even
noticing occurrence or labonery the
track we hunt is a track of wreckage as
if we followed a runaway cart down a
mountainside and watched it set off an
avalanche so there is some sort of evil
agency or entity that is doing something
but the
damage and in particular the despair
that we're seeing
spread throughout these islands where
magic is failing luck is failing craft
and knowledge is failing and personal
relationships are becoming undone
is one that was not intended out of
malice but rather is an effect of this
and so we can talk about despair is
perhaps one of the best names for what
we see going on in port town
and even more so in labonry
there's some similar interesting
dynamics that are taking place
in horton it's exacerbated
by the widespread use of an addiction to
a drug and
the guinea depicts it like this
here we go
they turned aside into a passage between
high red windless house walls which ran
along the hillside and through an
archway garlanded with decaying banners
out again into the sunlight into a steep
square another marketplace crowded with
booths and stalls and swarming with
people and flies
around the edges of the square
a number of men and women were sitting
or lying on their backs motionless
their mouths had a curious blackish look
as if they had been bruised and around
their lips flies swarmed and gathered in
clusters like bunches of dried currants
so many said sparrowhawk's voice low and
hasty as if he'd
too gotten a shock but when aaron looked
at him there was the blunt bland face of
the hearty traitor hawk
what's wrong with these people
hazia
it soothes and numbs letting the body be
free of the mind and the mind roams free
but when it returns to the body it needs
more hazia and the craving grows and the
life is short for the stuff is poison
first there's a trembling later
paralysis and then death erin looked at
a woman sitting with her back to a
sun-warmed wall she had raised her hand
as if to brush the flies from her face
but the hand made a jerky circular
motion in the air as if she'd quite
forgotten about it and was moved only by
the repeating surgery surging of a palsy
or shaking in the muscles the gesture
was like an incantation emptied of all
intention a spell without meaning and so
we have a mockery here of magic
intoxication
a
effect of the drug separating the mind
from the body
producing addiction on the part of many
people and as we're going to see with
the
former mage hair all sorts of delusions
as well
he tries to get ged and aaron to eat
hazia with him which they you know
prudently don't do
and he claims to have gone to all sorts
of other places in his drug delusions
we're going to talk about him shortly
first though we have to talk about this
more general malaise that shows itself
in different ways so in hort town
where things are not quite as bad as
they are on their bonnery
it's aaron
who recognizes some things and as leguin
recounts it
she says
there was indeed something wrong about
hort towns wrong in the very ear so one
might think seriously it lay
under a curse but this is not a presence
of any quality
rather an absence
a weakening of all qualities like a
sickness that soon infected the spirit
of any visitor the squares and streets
bustled with activity and business but
there was neither order nor prosperity
we'll see that even more so in labonry
goods were poor prices high the markets
were unsafe for vendors and buyers alike
being full of thieves and roaming gangs
not many women were on the streets and
the few there were appeared mostly in
groups it was a city without law and
governance
talking with people aaron and
sparrowhack soon learned there was no no
consul or mayor or lord left in port
town some of those who used to rule had
died some resigned some had been
assassinated
there was no center left to the city
the people for all their restless
activities seemed purposeless
craftsmen seemed to lack the will to
work well even the robbers robbed
because it was all they knew
how to do
all the brawl and brightness of a great
port city was there on the surface but
around the edges of it set the hazy
eaters motionless and under the surface
things did not seem entirely real
not even the faces the sounds the smells
they would fade away
so
what we have depicted here is a
kind of lifeless
only existing
on the surface's
existence not just of one person but
spread throughout the entire town the
entire society there's no center left is
the best way to put it there's nothing
that can provide centering
when we look at labonry this island
where they are seeking out the
famous dyers of labonry the people just
gather together in this this tavern
and essentially [ __ ] and wine they
complain about how things aren't good
anymore
and um one of them actually says
here we go the lux run out
uh that's what the lux ran out after
that there was not much more to say
the villagers departed by twos and
threes before that of course they're
they're claiming that you know the
seasons have been poor
scarcity puts up the prices nobody
really knows whether the dyes are any
good anymore and so there's again this
malaise
and
aaron again is is a good person for
talking about this he says
they're strange here
it's that way with everything they don't
know the difference like what one of
them said to the headman last night you
wouldn't know the true azure from blue
mud they complain about bad times but
they don't know when the bad times began
they say the work shoddy
but they don't improve it
they don't even know the difference
between an artisan and a spell worker
between handicraft and art magic here's
the key
it's as if they had no lines and
distinctions and colors clear in their
heads
everything is the same to them
everything's gray and then the uh ged
says
what is it they're missing and aaron
says without hesitation
joy in life there is no more joy in life
there
for them and they because of that don't
know the difference between different
things it's as if
without joy or appreciation for goods
their desires just go astray
a little bit later there's an
interesting exchange as the people of la
bonner are trying to get these these uh
foreigners out of there
um the mayor says people come to
lerbonnery for silk they don't come for
stones they don't come for charms or
armed wavings and jibber jabber and
sorcerer's trick honest folk live here
and do honest work interesting slogan
right
and he says and we don't want any other
sort here people from foreign parts
snooping about and prying into our
business and everybody else is saying
he's right that's right and if there was
any sorcery around here that wasn't
crazy we'd give him an honest job in the
sheds but they don't know how to do
honest work and then sparrowhawk or ged
says to them
they might if there was any to do
see you people don't actually do any
honest work your sheds are empty your
orchards are untended the silk in your
warehouses was all woven years ago what
do you actually do here in the battery
then the mayor says something really
interesting
we look after our own business
right
and their own business is basically
doing nothing but living in their
glories of the past and complaining
about the scarcities and bad luck of the
presence and now think about this
these sort of
existences the despair that's going on
the better times the directionlessness
the lack of joy the drug addiction this
is a stand-in for so many other places
and this is happening in the narrative
world of earthsea something that's a bit
unique to it is the various ruined
people of power
that gad and aaron are running across
the first one is not actually ruined
because she willfully withdrew
from things as she saw the proverbial
writing on the wall
ged says to her
um
when i was here years ago i saw you
pulling flames out of men's ears then
you made the flames turn into birds and
golden bells what was going on why
aren't you doing that
and the woman says listen we don't do
those tricks anymore people don't want
him they've seen through him they're
these mirrors now i see you remember my
mirrors you can puzzle a man's mind with
the flashing of the mirrors and with
words but
i don't do that it was tricks fooleries
you can fool men but after they've been
fooled they get angry and lose their
pleasure in such things so i turned my
attention to this trade selling
uh garments or selling silk selling
cloth right
then we run into hair
the mage and he is a genuinely ruined
person he's become addicted to hazia he
thinks that he's having all sorts of
visions of great things that he's
willing to try to show to get he's
encountered the evil presence that is
wrecking things he's also lost his hand
which he needed and as ged points out to
him
you must have stopped being a mage
before you lost your hand because if you
were a mage you wouldn't have lost your
hand you would have been able to prevent
it
and here
tells him
that here we go
i'm not i i'm only here we go i remember
being alive and i knew the words and
names and god says are you dead now
no alive i'm not dead i sleep sometimes
sleep comes very close to death the dead
walk and dreams everyone knows that they
come to you alive and they say things
and you could you can follow them and
you can find it if you know where to
look if you're willing to pay the price
and god says what's the price
life what else what else can you buy
life with
but life
and he goes on and he says men of power
have to
give it up they have to pay
pay what they pay
with their power and he says i'll i'll
use hazia to show you the way tonight
you can see
where i've gone
and so what we find out is that that
hair is just a wreck of a human being
he's lost his power he thinks he's got
something better in taking this drug
then at largonery we have this mother
and son the dyers of lerbonnery and
these are people of power as well
they are not uh mages but they are
people who used magic
in their dying and this is why
the
the cloths of labonry died with their
dies were so wonderful and fetched such
a
great price
so what we find
is that first he runs across
the mother and she's in a very bad way
so first she she you know says curse you
thieves and sparrowhack says avert right
and uh
she recognizes him as a person of power
as well and she says then
my power kept me from life so i lost it
i lost all the things i knew all the
words and names they came by little
strings like spider webs out of my eyes
and mouth and here she says something
very important
there's a hole in the world and light is
running out of it and the words go with
the light did you know that
my son sits staring all day at the dark
looking for the hole in the world he
says he would see better if he were
blind
they they go on as well and then um
she's she thinks that
he is the great man the king of shadows
the lord of the dark place and ged says
i am not that
and then
she says i'll tell you a secret
i don't want to live and live and live
forever i would rather have back the
names of things but they're all gone
names don't matter anymore there are no
more secrets do you wish to know my name
and she does reveal her name akaren this
is a very big thing in earthsea where
giving a person's name gives power over
them she is in such despair that she
doesn't care who has them she says now
they all know my secret name my true
name there are no secrets there is no
truth there is no death death death
ged gives her
a new name
he whispers in her ear so that she
now is no longer so vulnerable and then
he goes to find her son
soapley
the other dyer
and
what do we find out about him
soaply has also given up his his own
power
and wants to find this king in darkness
he says i found the hole in the darkness
the king was standing there he watches
it he rules it a little flame a little
candle in his hand he blew on it and it
went out then he blew on it again and it
burned it burned
he wants to find this place where
the king comes out a place
he says because he's alive not just the
spirits the ghosts that come over the
wall not just like that you can't bring
anything but souls over the wall but
this is the body this is the flesh
immortal i know that he has overcome
death i know it
i gave my wizardry to know it i was a
wizard once and you know it and you are
going there so what we find with these
people of power is either they've
abandoned their whatever their wizardry
or sorcery or witchcraft that they were
doing before like the cloth cellar
or it's been exchanged for
some sort of promise of eternal life in
the flesh
not just across the wall of stones in
the land of the dead
but it's bringing ruin with it it's
bringing despair
it's bringing in end to all things and
we have this pervasive
evil
that is taking place in all these
different dimensions
in horton and in
labonry representing the sickness
the imbalance that now has to be
addressed
you